Sitting in the chair operating a video camera, her feet do not even touch the ground. Her hair is braided in pigtails, Jasmine is just nine years old. On her video, first she interviews her mom, and then her mom interviews her.
坐在椅子上操作着摄像机，她的脚甚至碰不到地面。贾思敏今年才九岁，扎着辫子。在她的录像里，她先采访了妈妈，然后妈妈采访她。
Do you know how much I love you?
你知道我有多爱你吗？
Yes.
知道。
Do you know how proud I am of you?
你知道我有多为你感到骄傲吗？
Yes.
知道。
What do you want to be when you grow up?
你长大后想做什么？
A medical professor.
医学教授。
This is all taking place in a Texas prison. Jasmine's mom is in for aggravated assault with a deadly weapon. Jasmine's here with her Girl Scout troop. Everybody in the troop has a mom in prison. There are dozens of Girl Scout troops like this all across the country. A couple of filmmakers, Ellen Spiro and Karen Bernstein, put together a film about this troop called Troop 1500. And as part of it, they were there as the girls and their moms interviewed each other.
这一切都发生在德克萨斯州的一所监狱里。贾思敏的妈妈因持致命武器严重伤害他人而入狱。贾思敏是随女童子军小队来到这里的。小队里的每个人都有妈妈在监狱里。全国各地有几十个这样的女童子军小队。两位电影制作人艾伦·斯皮罗和凯伦·伯恩斯坦制作了一部关于这支小队的纪录片，名叫《1500小队》。作为纪录片的一部分，她们记录下了女孩们和她们的妈妈互相采访的过程。
How are you doing in school?
你在学校表现怎么样？
Great.
很好。
What do you went us to do when I come home?
当我回家时，你希望我们做什么？
Go to the zoo.
去动物园。
What's your favorite color?
你最喜欢的颜色是什么？
Blue.
蓝色。
I thought it was purple.
我还以为是紫色呢。
I like a whole lot of colors. I like maroon and blue and purple.
我喜欢的颜色很多。我喜欢褐红色、蓝色和紫色。
There are so many moments like this when the girls talk with their moms. Some of the girls do not want to disagree with their moms about anything, even when their mom gets their favorite color wrong. Other girls, it's hard to imagine how they're ever going to work it out with their moms. What's going on between them is like this thick web of cable that nobody is ever going to be able to untangle. Jessica is nine. She wears big, silver headphones that are plugged into the camera. When her mom talks, Jessica hugs the big legal pad with her questions tightly to her chest.
当女孩们和妈妈交谈时，这样的时刻有很多。有些女孩不想在任何事情上与妈妈有分歧，即使妈妈说错了她们最喜欢的颜色。而对于其他女孩来说，很难想象她们将如何与妈妈处理好关系。她们之间的联系就像一团乱麻，没人能解开。杰西卡九岁，戴着插在摄像机上的大银色耳机。当妈妈说话时，杰西卡紧紧地抱着写有问题的笔记本，贴在胸前。
OK, let's see. I don't remember what I asked first.
好了，看看。我不记得我先问了什么。
(SUBJECT) JESSICA It doesn't matter. Start from number one.
没关系。从第一个开始。
OK, don't be acting silly now. Let's not act retarded, OK? Move your hair out of your eyes first. What do you say when people ask you where your mom is?
好吧，别胡闹了。别装傻，好吗？先把头发从眼睛上拨开。当别人问你妈妈在哪里时，你怎么说？
(SUBJECT) JESSICA I don't know.
我不知道。
Re you embarrassed that I'm in prison?
你觉得我在监狱里很丢人吗？
(SUBJECT) JESSICA Yes.
是的。
Does it embarrass you?
这让你感到尴尬吗？
(SUBJECT) JESSICA No, you ask me, are you mad at me.
不，你问我，你是不是生我的气。
I'll ask you that in a minute. Jessica, come on baby.
我一会儿会问你那个。杰西卡，来吧，宝贝。
(SUBJECT) JESSICA OK, just go.
好吧，开始吧。
Put your legs together. Thank you. Do you like coming here with the Girl Scouts to see me?
把腿并拢。谢谢。你喜欢和女童子军一起来看我吗？
(SUBJECT) JESSICA Duh.
废话。
Yeah. That's good. Have you learned any tricks on your new bike?
嗯。那很好。你的新自行车学会什么花样了吗？
(SUBJECT) JESSICA Yeah. Falling off.
会了。摔跤。
Yeah, that'd be a good one. Let me see--.
嗯，那倒是个好花样。让我看看——。
(SUBJECT) JESSICA Mom, I need to go to the restroom.
妈妈，我要去洗手间。
Well, let us finish this up--.
好吧，让我们先完成这个——。
(SUBJECT) JESSICA I need to go very bad.
我急需去一下。
Jessica, can't you just hold on just another minute? Do you know how much I love you?
杰西卡，你就不能再等一分钟吗？你知道我有多爱你吗？
(SUBJECT) JESSICA To the stars and to the world and back.
爱到星星，爱到全世界，然后再回到这里。
Say it right.
好好说。
(SUBJECT) JESSICA To the stars and to the world and back.
爱到星星，爱到全世界，然后再回到这里。
Other moms sound like really good mothers, doing everything possible under the circumstances to be close to their girls. And you just kind of cross your fingers for them that it's going to be enough. Kenya is a neatly put together inmate in a white prison jumpsuit. She's in for possession with intent to distribute, and gives heartfelt answers when her 14 year old, Caitlin, asks a series of astonishingly direct questions. When you get out of prison, will you still have a boyfriend who does drugs? Why did you start selling drugs again after you'd already been in prison for it once before?
其他妈妈看起来都是很好的母亲，在那种情况下尽一切可能与女儿保持亲近。你只能为她们祈祷，希望这样就足够了。肯尼亚是一个穿着白色囚服、打扮整洁的囚犯。她因持有毒品并意图分销而入狱，当她14岁的女儿凯特琳问出一系列令人震惊的直接问题时，她给出了真诚的回答。当你出狱后，你还会有一个吸毒的男朋友吗？你为什么在因为卖毒品坐过一次牢之后又开始卖了？
I worked. You know I had a job, but it wasn't enough money. It was just a decision I made, which was a wrong decision. I wanted things, and I went about it the wrong way to get it.
我工作过。你知道我有份工作，但钱不够。那只是我做的一个决定，一个错误的决定。我想要东西，但我用了错误的方式去得到它们。
OK. Were you around drugs when you were little?
好吧。你小时候周围有毒品吗？
Yes.
有。
With who?
和谁在一起？
My mother. My mother always sold marijuana. And when I was 12, my mother started doing crack.
我妈妈。我妈妈一直卖大麻。我12岁时，我妈妈开始吸快克。
I didn't even know grandma did that.
我甚至不知道奶奶做过那种事。
Well, she's been clean for about 16 years. My mom didn't go to prison, but she was gone from me all the time, and I know how it feels. And I felt like she didn't love me. I felt like she didn't care about me, because she'd just leave. And I don't want y'all to feel like that.
嗯，她已经戒掉大约16年了。我妈妈虽然没坐牢，但她总是离开我，我知道那种感觉。我觉得她不爱我。我觉得她不在乎我，因为她总是离开。我不希望你们有那种感觉。
How is it like living with grandma?
和奶奶住在一起感觉怎么样？
It's fun.
很有趣。
I mean besides the fun.
我是说除了有趣之外。
Like, what do you mean?
什么意思？
You know how she's dramatic and stuff. You know how she cries or she gets upset or she's really emotional?
你知道她总是很大惊小怪之类的。你知道她怎么哭，或者怎么心烦意乱，或者她真的很情绪化？
Yeah, and Alex does not help at all.
是啊，而且亚历克斯一点忙也帮不上。
That's grown up stuff she's going through. Don't concern yourself with that, because your job is to go to school, stay out of trouble, be a kid. Like you told me the other day that grandma is stressed out about money. Well, that's not your concern, because you're not even old enough to get a job yet. You know what I mean? What could you do?
那是她正在经历的大人的事情。别担心那个，因为你的工作是去上学，别惹麻烦，做个孩子。就像前几天你告诉我奶奶因为钱而感到压力。嗯，那不是你应该担心的，因为你还没到能工作的年龄。你知道我的意思吗？你能做什么呢？
I'm almost there.
快了。
Just be a kid.
做个孩子就好。
Of course it's hard just being a kid when your mom is in prison. What can your mom really say to you that's going to help? She can't make you a nice meal, or give you a nice place to live. She can't read to you at night or tuck you into bed. She can't be there to hear about your day. All she can do is hug you, show you that she loves you, give a little advice maybe, and just hope that's going to hold you, and you'll be OK until the next visit.
当然，当你的妈妈在监狱里时，想做一个单纯的孩子很难。妈妈真的能对你说些什么来帮到你呢？她不能给你做顿美餐，也不能给你提供一个舒适的住处。她不能在晚上为你读书，也不能把你掖进被窝。她不能在你身边听你讲述这一天发生的事。她唯一能做的就是拥抱你，告诉你她爱你，也许给你一点建议，并希望这就足够支撑你，让你在下一次探视前一切安好。
Well, today on our radio show, Parental Guidance Suggested. We have a bunch of stories where kids are not allowed to be kids, where they want somebody to look out for them and be the parent, and where parents get into impossible situations where it's hard to be a parent, which, I got to say, sometimes makes for really sad stories, and sometimes makes for really, really funny stories. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our show today in three acts-- act one, Two Possibilities, Both of Them Bad. In that act, a kid and a parent face an impossible choice together. Act two, The Grandma Letters, a miserable teenager and his miserable grandma correspond. Act three, My Angels in the Centerfolds. In that act, a 10 year old girl starts her own business with a phone, a collection of index cards, and her dad's old Playboy magazines. Stay with us.
今天在我们的广播节目《需要家长指导》中。我们有一些关于孩子们被禁止做回孩子的故事，他们希望有人能照顾他们，担起父母的责任，而父母们也陷入了难以作为家长的困境，这有时会带来非常悲伤的故事，有时也会带来非常、非常有趣的故事。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分三幕——第一幕，两种可能性，都很糟糕。在这一幕中，一个孩子和一位家长共同面临一个不可能的选择。第二幕，奶奶的信，一个可怜的少年和他可怜的奶奶之间的通信。第三幕，折页里的天使。在这一幕中，一个10岁的女孩用一部电话、一叠索引卡和她爸爸的旧《花花公子》杂志开启了自己的生意。请继续收听。
Act one, Two Possibilities, Both Bad. What's amazing about this story is that the people in it make one reasonable choice after another. But they're living in such an unreasonable time and place that eventually, they're forced into a position that no family should ever really be in at all. It all happened to Gene Cheek. And when the story begins, he's 10 years old, growing up in Winston-Salem, North Carolina. It's 1961. His parents split up long ago. He lives with his mom. And partly because it's just the two of them, they're really, really close. She spends a lot of time with him. And one day, he comes in from playing outside.
第一幕，两种可能性，都很糟糕。这个故事令人称奇之处在于，其中的人做出的每一个选择都是合理的。但他们生活在一个如此不合理的时代和地方，最终他们被迫陷入了一种任何家庭都不该经历的境地。这一切都发生在吉恩·奇克身上。故事开始时，他10岁，在北卡罗来纳州的温斯顿-塞勒姆长大。那是1961年。他的父母很久以前就分开了。他和妈妈住在一起。也因为他们俩相依为命，所以非常亲密。她花了很多时间陪他。有一天，他从外面玩回来。
And Mama was on the phone crying. And I thought somebody had died or something was wrong. So I stood at her door for a minute. And she eventually, after much pressure from me, eventually told me that that was her boyfriend on the phone, or a man that she had been seeing, is the way she put it. And I didn't even know. All she did was work and come home. I didn't know when she had time to have a boyfriend.
妈妈在电话里哭。我以为有人去世了或者出什么事了。所以我在她门口站了一会儿。最终，在我的多次追问下，她告诉我那是她的男朋友在电话里，或者按照她的说法，是一个她一直在见面的男人。我甚至都不知道。她平时除了工作就是回家。我不知道她哪来的时间交男朋友。
Tuck was what everybody called him. His name was Cornelius Tucker. And my mom and Tuck worked together, and we talked about it. And I said, why are you crying? What'd he do to make you cry? And she said, nothing. He thinks we should stop seeing each other for your sake. And I said, well, why does he think I will have a problem with him seeing you? And she said, because he's black.
大家都叫他塔克。他的名字叫科尼利厄斯·塔克。我妈妈和塔克一起工作，我们谈论了这件事。我说，你为什么要哭？他做了什么让你哭？她说，没做什么。他认为为了你好，我们应该停止见面。我说，好吧，他为什么觉得我会介意他和你会面？她说，因为他是黑人。
Was there any part of you at that point which flinched a little when she said that? You're a little kid growing up in the south. You probably didn't have much contact, or were close to any black people.
当你妈说那句话的时候，你心里有没有一点退缩？作为一个在南方长大的小孩子。你可能和黑人没什么接触，或者和他们不亲近。
I did flinch a little. We didn't live too far from the African American community, a couple of streets over. So you would see them in your daily lives, going through their neighborhoods, or going through yours to get to theirs. But that was it, really. Jim Crow civil rights was at its beginning. Blacks were being killed, lynched, beaten. I was aware that this was not going to be a very popular thing.
我确实有点退缩。我们住的地方离非裔美国人社区不太远，隔了几条街。所以你在日常生活中会看到他们，他们会经过你的社区，或者你为了去某个地方而经过他们的社区。但真的也就仅此而已。吉姆·克劳民权法当时刚刚开始。黑人在被杀害、私刑处死、殴打。我意识到这不是一件会被大众欢迎的事情。
And so how soon after that did you finally meet Tuck?
那你是什么时候见到塔克的？
A couple of days later. He wanted to give me a birthday present, even though it wasn't my birthday. So he drove by at night and circled our block. I walked outside our apartment and walked around the corner. And he went by to make sure he wasn't being followed, circled back, and the second time around, he slowed down, rolled down his window, and said catch, and threw out a football.
几天后。他想给我一个生日礼物，虽然那天不是我生日。所以他在晚上开车过来，在我们街区绕圈。我走出公寓，绕过街角。他经过时确定没有人跟踪，转了一圈回来，第二次经过时，他慢了下来，摇下车窗，说了声“接住”，然后扔出一个橄榄球。
And could you even see him? Or was it just this mysterious voice and then a football?
你当时能看见他吗？还是只有一个神秘的声音，然后就是一个橄榄球？
Yeah, it was night, and I couldn't see him, really. You could see a figure inside the car. I assumed it was him. Mama told me what kind of car he would be driving.
是的，天很黑，我真的看不见他。你可以看到车里有个影子。我假设那就是他。妈妈告诉我他开的是什么车。
That is so secret agent. Was this pretty much the coolest thing that had ever happened to you?
这太像秘密特工了。这是你经历过的最酷的事情吗？
Oh yeah, definitely. And it was exactly that, secret agent man.
哦，是的，绝对是。完全就是那个样子，秘密特工的感觉。
Now this is 1961, so it's six years before the Supreme Court rules that interracial marriage is legal nationwide. Was it legal for her to see him?
现在是1961年，距离最高法院裁定跨种族婚姻在全国范围内合法还有六年。她和他在法律上是被允许见面的吗？
It was not legal. Well, it was illegal for them to be boyfriend- girlfriend, or any other kind of relationship, as far as that goes.
不合法。嗯，只要是男女朋友，或者任何其他关系，在当时都是非法的。
And so would you start to see him? Were you in situations where it would be the three of you and you would hang out?
那你开始见他了吗？有没有你们三个人待在一起的情况？
Absolutely. Mom and I would leave our house after dark and we would walk around the corner. Normally we would cover our faces as much as possible. Mama wore a scarf, and I had a coat that I would pull up the collar on, and a baseball cap, and that kind of thing. And again, Tuck would circle by and keep going, to make sure he wasn't followed. And he would turn around and come back from the other direction, pull up to the curb and we would jump in.
当然。妈妈和我会天黑后离开家，然后绕过街角。通常我们会尽量遮住脸。妈妈戴着围巾，我有一件外套，我会把领子竖起来，再戴上一顶棒球帽，之类的东西。同样，塔克会绕过来，保持行驶，以确保没有被跟踪。他会转回来，从另一个方向过来，靠边停车，我们就跳上车。
And when you were in the car, would you have to duck down so people couldn't see you?
当你在车里时，你是不是得蹲下去以免被别人看到？
Yeah. I would be scrunched down in the seat, so that I wasn't as visible. Normally, we would pull up in his driveway and sit in the car for a minute or two just to make sure that we hadn't been followed. We would get out, and it would be dark, of course, and the porch light would not be on. And we would go into the house and do what normal people did-- talk, play games, Monopoly , card games, watch TV, listened to the radio, listened to the stereo, played marbles on his floor. He had a carpet and he would take a piece of chalk and draw a circle on the carpet, and we would shoot marbles.
是的。我会蜷缩在座位上，这样就不那么显眼了。通常，我们会停在他的车道上，在车里坐上一两分钟，确保没有人跟踪。我们会下车，当然那时候天很黑，门廊灯也不会亮。我们会进屋，做正常人做的事——聊天、玩游戏、大富翁、打牌、看电视、听收音机、听音响，在地板上玩弹珠。他有地毯，他会用粉笔在地毯上画个圈，然后我们比赛打弹珠。
Tuck was an amazing human being, and he had a way of just immediately putting you at ease. After the first night that I met him and spent time at his house, it was easy for me to see how mama had fallen in love with him. He was just that kind of a man.
塔克是一个了不起的人，他有一种让人立刻放松下来的本领。在我第一次见到他并在他家待过之后，我就很容易理解妈妈为什么会爱上他了。他就是那种男人。
And then would you stay over there, and then go to school from there in the morning?
那你当时会留在那里过夜，然后第二天直接去学校吗？
No. No, we never spent the night. And Tuck had made it plain that we had to be very careful. I was oblivious. I was just caught up in the espionage of it all-- that I had a secret that nobody else knew.
不。不，我们从没在那里过夜。塔克明确表示我们必须非常小心。但我当时什么都不知道。我只是沉浸在这一切的间谍活动中——我有一个别人都不知道的秘密。
Oh right, you couldn't even tell kids at school.
哦，对了，你甚至不能告诉学校的小伙伴。
Oh, heck no. God no. I couldn't tell anybody. I couldn't tell my best friend. Couldn't tell anyone.
哦，当然不能。天哪，绝不能。我不能告诉任何人。我不能告诉我也最好的朋友。不能告诉任何人。
And how far did it go? Like how often was there something where there was trouble?
这种情况发展到什么程度？也就是说，多久会有一次麻烦？
Well, we got chased. The police would come by and they would knock on the door, or just open the door sometimes, and just walk right in. And we would be sitting in the living room talking, or sitting at the kitchen table playing games, and they would say, nigger, what are you doing with this white woman? And he would say, we're just friends. We're just visiting. And then they would say something to my mom, don't you know better? What's your son doing here? And she said, well, what's wrong with my son being here? Well, you can't stay here. Don't you know it's illegal for you and that nigger to be sleeping together?
嗯，我们会被追赶。警察会过来，他们会敲门，或者有时直接推开门走进来。我们正坐在客厅里聊天，或者坐在餐桌旁玩游戏，他们就会说：“黑鬼，你跟这个白人女人在干什么？”他会说，我们只是朋友。我们只是在串门。然后他们会对我妈妈说，你难道不知道好歹吗？你儿子在这里干什么？她说，我儿子在这里有什么错？好吧，你不能留在这里。难道你不知道你和那个黑鬼睡觉是违法的吗？
But they would always say, you and your boy are going to have to leave. And Tuck would say, OK, they were just leaving. I'll take them home. And they would say, oh, hell no, nigger, we'll take them home. You're lucky we don't arrest you. So that's usually the way it went.
但他们总是会说，你和你的孩子得离开。塔克会说，好的，他们正要离开。我送他们回家。他们会说，噢，去他的，黑鬼，我们送他们回家。你算走运的，我们没逮捕你。所以通常就是这样。
That happened how many times?
这种事发生过多少次？
It would happen once a month probably, or once every six weeks. Once it was known that mama was seeing Tuck--.
大概一个月一次，或者六周一次。一旦妈妈和塔克见面的事传开了——。
How did it get to be known?
是怎么传开的？
Well, my dad followed my mom-- my biological father had followed my mom. Him and his brother followed my mom to Tuck's house. There was one time when the cops came and as we walked outside Tuck's house, I could see my dad and his brother parked down the street. So I knew who had brought the cops with them.
嗯，我爸爸跟踪了我妈妈——我的亲生父亲跟踪了我妈妈。他和他的兄弟跟踪我妈到了塔克的家。有一次警察来了，当我们走出塔克家的时候，我可以看到我爸爸和他的兄弟把车停在街尾。所以我知道是谁把警察带来的。
So your dad called the cops on your mom. Why?
所以你爸爸报警举报了你妈妈。为什么？
Well, because he was full of hate. It was bad enough that his wife had left him, but she was now seeing a black man. My dad was a stone cold racist, and that was more than he could stand.
嗯，因为他充满了仇恨。他妻子离开他已经够让他受的了，现在她还跟一个黑人男人来往。我爸爸是一个顽固的种族主义者，这让他无法忍受。
Would he lecture you about it?
他会为此教训你吗？
Oh yeah. Oh God yeah.
噢，会。天哪，会的。
What would he say?
他会说什么？
He would say it was unnatural, and it was against God's law, and those kinds of things. He would use the analogy, you don't see a black bird and a red bird together. And I always wanted to say, well yeah those are different species there, Dad, not just different colors.
他会说这是不自然的，这是违背上帝律法的，诸如此类的话。他会用这个比喻，你说你见过黑鸟和红鸟在一起吗？我总是想说，噢，那是不同物种，爸爸，不仅仅是颜色不同。
And so Tuck and your mom, they also got fired from their jobs, right?
那塔克和你妈，他们也被解雇了，对吧？
They did. My little brother was born. That kind of changed things. It's pretty difficult to hide that. They got fired from their jobs at the mill. My mom's family, my dad's family, our friends, everybody disowned us, walked out of our lives, didn't have anything to do with us after Randy was born. My aunt-- her sister-- came to visit her in the hospital. She had checked into the hospital under an assumed name. But Aunt Goldie went to see her, and when she saw Randy, she said, Sally, this baby ain't white. And Mama said, I know Goldie, but he's still my son. And Aunt Goldie handed Randy back to Mama, and walked out of our lives. And it was 30 years later before they ever spoke again.
是的。我弟弟出生了。那改变了一些事情。隐藏这件事变得相当困难。他们在工厂的工作被解雇了。我妈妈的家人、我爸爸的家人、我们的朋友，所有人都不认我们了，走出了我们的生活，在兰迪出生后就再也没有跟我们来往了。我的姑姑——她姐姐——去医院看她。妈妈当时是用化名登记入院的。但是戈尔迪姑姑去看她，当她看到兰迪时，她说，萨莉，这个孩子不是白人。妈妈说，我知道，戈尔迪，但他还是我儿子。戈尔迪姑姑把兰迪还给妈妈，然后走出了我们的生活。那是30年后他们才再次说话。
And about eight months after Randy was born, we had gone to bed one night during the week, and I was awakened at 2 o'clock in the morning by sounds outside. And I could see through the curtain that there was something burning, and I didn't really know what it was. And when I pulled back the curtain, I could see three Klansmen. One of them had a shotgun, and was shooting it into the air, which is what had woke me up. And they had put a cross on the yard and were shouting racial slurs-- death to nigger lovers, and those kinds of things.
在兰迪出生大约八个月后，有一天晚上我们睡下了，凌晨2点我被外面的声音吵醒了。透过窗帘，我看到外面有什么东西在燃烧，我不知道那是什么。当我拉开窗帘，我看到三个三K党人。其中一个人拿着一把散弹枪，正向空中射击，这就是把我吵醒的原因。他们在院子里放了一个十字架，大喊着种族歧视的口号——“黑鬼爱人去死”，之类的话。
And Mama woke up. And when she came in, she said, get away from the window. It's the Klan. And of course, I know what the Klan was. And  I said, what are they doing here? And she said, they're here because of your brother. And I was just infuriated. We spent the night sitting in the living room. And I had gone to the kitchen and got a butcher knife, and I'd taken a chair and set it facing the front door, and sat there thinking they were going to bust in at any minute. And we didn't have a phone, so we couldn't call anybody.
妈妈醒了。她进来时说，离窗户远点。是三K党。当然，我知道三K党是什么。我说，他们在这里干什么？她说，他们是因为你弟弟才在这里。我当时气疯了。我们整晚坐在客厅里。我去厨房拿了一把屠夫刀，拿了一把椅子对着前门坐着，心想他们随时会冲进来。我们没有电话，所以不能打给任何人。
If she could have called somebody, was there actually somebody who she could have called, who could have come over?
如果她能打电话给某人，有没有人是可以帮她并能赶过来的？
She could have called Tuck. The police probably would not have done anything at that time.
她可以打电话给塔克。警察当时可能什么都不会做。
Could she have called her family? Wouldn't they have stepped in to rescue you, even if they were having this fight?
她能打电话给她的家人吗？即使他们闹翻了，他们就不会出手相救吗？
No, not at this point. No. Her family had turned their backs on her and her family would not have lifted a finger. Her \ probably sent the Klan in the first place, if you want to know the truth about it. She had nobody.
不，这个时候不会。不。她的家人已经背弃了她，他们不会伸出援手。如果你想知道真相的话，甚至可能是她家人先把三K党叫来的。她什么人都没有。
Why not just move north?
为什么不搬到北方去？
Well, we had talked about it. Tuck asked me. He said that we could move up north and be more like a family. He said, your mom and I could even get married. But you got to understand that we didn't have any money. Tuck didn't have any money. It was not like we could just gather up what we owned and off we went.
我们讨论过。塔克问过我。他说我们可以搬到北方去，像个正常家庭一样生活。他说，你妈和我甚至可以结婚。但你必须明白，我们没钱。塔克也没钱。我们不能像把拥有的东西打包就走那样简单。
I know. But so many poor people move north. I mean, the whole city of Chicago is like people who had nothing, who just picked up and moved.
我知道。但很多穷人搬到了北方。我的意思是，整个芝加哥市就是由一无所有的人组成的，他们只是收拾行李就搬过来了。
I know. And the only thing I can look back on now and say is that things happened so fast. From the time Randy was born, things just spiraled out of control before they could get a handle on it. They didn't expect things to turn out like they did.
我知道。现在回顾过去，我只能说事情发生得太快了。从兰迪出生起，事情就失控了，他们还没反应过来。他们没预料到事情会变成那样。
Things turned out like they did because of what happened next. And what happened next is that his mom told him that they had to go to court for child support. They'd been fighting with his father over child support payments for years, so Gene wasn't especially worried about this.
事情变成那样是因为接下来发生的事。接下来发生的是，他妈妈告诉他，他们必须去法院处理抚养费问题。多年来他们一直因为抚养费支付问题和他父亲争执，所以吉恩并没有特别担心。
Mom and I rode the bus downtown, and then walked into the courtroom by ourselves. And we sat on the right side of the courtroom, and on the left side was my dad, his brother, my grandmother, Mom's brother, Uncle Bill, our next door neighbors. And on our side of the courtroom was me and Mom. And when the judge walked in, he said, in the matter of the custody of Jesse Eugene Cheek. And I knew immediately what that meant; that we were not here for child support. And Mom's lawyer didn't show up, he never did show up. So it was all downhill after that.
妈妈和我坐公交车去市中心，然后独自走进了法庭。我们坐在法庭的右侧，左侧是我爸爸、他的兄弟、我的祖母、我妈妈的兄弟、比尔叔叔、我们的邻居。而我们这边只有我和妈妈。当法官进来时，他说：“关于杰西·尤金·奇克的监护权问题。”我立刻就知道这意味着什么；我们不是来处理抚养费的。我妈妈的律师没来，他一直没出现。所以从那之后一切就一落千丈了。
She had told her sister the day before this trial that there's no way they'll take Gene away from me, I'm a good mother. And she believed that. She was convinced that they would not take me away from her, because she was a good mother. And I'm here to tell you that she was. There was nobody in that courtroom that day that could testify that she was not a good mother. And nobody did. What they did testify was that she had a mixed race baby by an African American man and was therefore unfit.
审判前一天，她曾告诉她姐姐，他们没理由把吉恩从我身边带走，我是个好母亲。她对此深信不疑。她确信他们不会把我带走，因为她是个好母亲。我在这里告诉你，她是。那天法庭上没有人能证明她不是个好母亲。也没有人这么做。他们作证的内容是，她和一个非裔美国男人生了一个混血儿，因此不适合抚养孩子。
Now one strange thing about this case is that your dad wasn't actually trying to get you back himself, right?
关于这个案件有一件奇怪的事情，你爸爸其实并不是想亲自把你接回去，对吧？
No.
没有。
Explain what your dad was arguing in court.
解释一下你爸爸在法庭上的论点。
He was arguing that Mama was unfit. But he told the judge that he, himself was an alcoholic and an epileptic, and could not raise me. His brother-- my uncle-- testified that he could not provide me with a home either, because he had his own family to raise. My grandmother-- my dad's mom-- testified that she could not offer me a home either, because her doctor had advised her that having a teenage boy in the house would be bad for her health. And so they all testified that mama was unfit, but they couldn't take me for this reason or that reason.
他辩称妈妈不适合抚养。但他告诉法官，他自己是酗酒者和癫痫患者，不能抚养我。他的兄弟——我的叔叔——作证说他也无法为我提供一个家，因为他有自己的家庭要养。我的祖母——我爸爸的妈妈——作证说她也不能给我提供一个家，因为她的医生建议她，家里有一个十几岁的男孩会对她的健康不利。所以他们都作证说妈妈不适合，但他们因为各种原因无法抚养我。
It's just so crazy, the notion of a parent going in and saying, well, she's unfit, but I'm unfit too, so I can't take the kid. I've never heard of a custody hearing that works like that.
这太疯狂了，父母去法庭说，“好吧，她不适合，但我也一样不适合，所以我不能要这个孩子。”我从未听说过这样的监护权听证会。
Well, that's exactly what he said. I mean, that's honest to God exactly what he said. My dad was a rare bird.
嗯，他说的就是那个。我的意思是，上帝作证，他说的确实就是这个。我爸爸是个怪胎。
And then when the judge asked your mom, is the father Tuck-- because I know as part of the court proceeding, he actually asked her flat out, is this guy the father of this baby? What did she say?
当法官问你妈妈，父亲是不是塔克——因为我知道作为法庭程序的一部分，他确实直接问她，这个男人是这个婴儿的父亲吗？她说了什么？
No. She denied it. She said that the father was a truck driver, who is now deceased. And that's all she said about the matter.
没有。她否认了。她说父亲是个卡车司机，现在已经去世了。关于这件事她只说了这些。
And didn't they ask, who is this guy? What's his name?
他们没问，这个人是谁吗？他叫什么名字？
No, they didn't.
没有，他们没问。
Because they just could see that this is a lie?
因为他们看得出这是个谎言？
Sure. Well, they knew she was lying. But it was a felony for her to admit in a court of law that she had a baby by Cornelius Tucker. So she had to lie about it. She had to say, no, it's not Cornelius Tucker's baby. The father's dead, I don't remember his name.
当然。嗯，他们知道她在撒谎。但如果她在法庭上承认她和科尼利厄斯·塔克生了一个孩子，那是重罪。所以她必须撒谎。她必须说，不，这不是科尼利厄斯·塔克的孩子。父亲死了，我不记得他名字。
It didn't take long for Gene and his mother to figure out this hearing was not going very well for them. Gene's mom started crying. He started crying. Gene says he simply had no idea the world could work the way it was working in the courtroom that day. It was incomprehensible. It was shocking.
吉恩和他的母亲没花多长时间就意识到这场听证会对他们来说非常不利。吉恩的妈妈开始哭。我也开始哭。吉恩说他根本不知道世界可以像那天在法庭上那样运作。那是不可理解的。这是令人震惊的。
I didn't believe it. Mama didn't believe it. We believed right won out. When the judge made his ruling, that it's the ruling of this court that your son be-- actually, he gave my mom a choice. He said give up this baby, is the way he put it, I believe, or give up your son.
我不相信。妈妈也不相信。我们相信正义终会获胜。当法官做出裁决时，他说“本庭裁定你的儿子被……”——实际上，他给了我妈妈一个选择。我想他说的是：“要么放弃这个婴儿，要么放弃你的儿子。”
Let me just be sure I'm totally understanding the logic. The logic of that is, OK, what makes her an unfit mother is that she's got this mixed race baby.
让我确定我完全理解了这个逻辑。逻辑是，好的，让她成为不称职母亲的原因是她有个混血宝宝。
Right, and I'm around him.
对，而且我和他待在一起。
And you're around him, and you'll be exposed to this mixed race baby.
而你和他在接触，你会被这个混血宝宝影响。
That's right. Yeah, it'll rub off on me, I guess. Whatever.
没错。是的，我想这会传染给我什么的。不管怎样。
And so basically, if you get the baby out of this picture, then she's suddenly a fit mother again by abandoning her baby?
所以基本上，如果你让这个婴儿离开，那么通过抛弃她的婴儿，她就突然又变成了一个称职的母亲？
With the choice he gave her, that's exactly what he was saying, yeah. Somehow this will all be better, if they're not around each other. It'll all be better.
根据他给出的选择，这正是他所说的，是的。不管怎么说，如果他们不待在一起，一切都会变好。一切都会变好。
How does that make sense?
这怎么解释得通？
Yeah, I don't know. It don't make sense. It wasn't meant to make sense. It was just more punishment, as far as I was concerned.
是的，我不知道。这解释不通。它本来就没打算讲得通。在我看来，这不过是更多的惩罚。
And so does a judge actually say to her, OK, here you are, just choose which kid are you going to give up?
所以法官真的对她说，好了，就在这儿，选一个孩子放弃吗？
Not in those exact words. But his words were-- I'm going to paraphrase-- but he said, Mrs. Cheek, you can give up your illegitimate son, or we're going to take Gene away from you. One or the other. I just looked at Mama and I leaned over and I whispered and said, Mama, if they take Randy, we'll never see him again. He's just a baby. And I said, I know where home is, let them take me. And before she could say anything, I just turned to the judge and said, take me. And so that was enough. He did. He pounded the gavel and said, it's the ruling of this court that Jesse Eugene Cheek will be removed and placed in the custody of Forsythe County Child Services.
没用那样的原话。但我可以转述他的话——他说，“奇克太太，你可以放弃你那个非婚生的儿子，或者我们要把吉恩从你身边带走。二选一。”我看着妈妈，俯身低声说：“妈妈，如果他们带走兰迪，我们就永远看不到他了。他还是个婴儿。我知道家在哪，让他们带走我吧。”她还没来得及说什么，我就转过头对法官说：“带我走吧。”那这就够了。他确实这么做了。他敲了法槌说：“本庭裁定，杰西·尤金·奇克将被带走，交由福赛斯县儿童服务中心监管。”
And at that time, two policemen, who had been standing in the back of the courtroom, came down. And Mama and I were clinging to each other. I was holding onto her and she was holding onto me. And she was screaming, don't do this, don't do this. And I was cussing, screaming at my dad, I'll kill you for this. And so the cops took me by the arms and literally pulled me away, tore me away from my mom, and just drug me out of the courtroom. They put me in a police car, drove me to a detention center that was a couple of blocks from the courthouse, for juvenile delinquents. A lady got up from behind a desk, went to the end of the hall and unlocked a door. The two policemen pushed me into the room, the door was pulled shut behind me and locked. And I spent three days in that room.
当时，一直站在法庭后面的两名警察走了过来。妈妈和我紧紧拥抱在一起。我抱着她，她也抱着我。她尖叫着：“别这样，别这样。”我在咒骂，对着我爸爸尖叫：“我会为了这个杀了你。”警察抓着我的胳膊，硬生生地把我从妈妈身边拉开，把我从法庭拖了出去。他们把我塞进警车，把我带到一个离法院几个街区远的少管所。一位女士从办公桌后站起来，走到走廊尽头打开了一扇门。两名警察把我推了进去，门在我身后关上并锁上了。我在那个房间里待了三天。
They fed me by slipping trays of food under the door. Those three days, two and a half days, that I spent locked in that room, all I did was cry and sleep, really. I was devastated. My life had ended as I knew it. When I came out of that room, I was an angry kid, and I stayed angry until a few years ago, to be honest with you.
他们通过把托盘从门下塞进来给我送饭。那三天，我在那个房间里被关了大约两天半，我什么都没做，只是哭和睡觉。我崩溃了。我所知的生活结束了。当我走出那个房间时，我成了一个愤怒的孩子，老实说，直到几年前我一直都很愤怒。
Gene was sent to a foster home on the other side of town, but he was like a different kid. He was not the well-behaved boy that he'd been. He was in the crazy position that he had done the right thing. He'd volunteered to leave his own family, for the sake of everybody. It was better for his baby brother. It was better for his mom. The main person it wasn't better for was him. And though he knew he did the right thing, he had other feelings about it too.
吉恩被送到了城另一边的寄养家庭，但他像个变了个人。他不再是以前那个表现良好的男孩了。他处于一种疯狂的境地，他做了正确的事。他为了大家的利益自愿离开自己的家庭。这对他的小弟弟更好。这对他的妈妈更好。唯一没变好的人就是他自己。虽然他知道他做了正确的事，但他对此也有别的感受。
Somewhere along the line, that little 12 year old boy that got taken away from his mama expected-- as all 12 year old boys do-- that his mama would make things all right. And I was mad at her because she didn't make things all better.
在某个阶段，那个被带离妈妈的12岁小男孩本以为——正如所有12岁男孩所想的那样——他的妈妈会让一切好起来。但我生她的气，因为她没能让一切好起来。
Right, that she didn't sweep in and move you all north?
对，因为她没能带着你们全部搬到北方去？
Yeah. And that everything was just all better all of a sudden. And I guess for the first two or three months in that foster home, I held onto the possibility that things would be all right. But you lose hope of that pretty quick. And I did.
是的。而且一切都没有突然变好。我想在寄养家庭的前两三个月，我一直抱有事情会好起来的希望。但你很快就会失去希望。我确实失去了。
I was a terrible foster kid. I beat the heck out of her own son the first day I was there because he was standing on the back porch-- I had just come back from a walk-- and he said, you're the one with the nigger loving mama. And it was the wrong time for him to say that. So I was a pretty bad kid. I would skip school and go see my mom, and ride the bus, hitchhike, walk across town, ride a bike. I would go see her anytime I wanted to.
我是一个糟糕的寄养孩子。我第一天去就狠狠揍了那家人的儿子，因为他当时站在后廊——我刚散步回来——他说：“你就是那个跟黑鬼爱人妈妈住一起的。”对他来说那不是个好时机。所以我真是个坏孩子。我会逃学去见我妈，坐公交车、搭便车、步行穿过全城、骑自行车。我想见她的时候就会去见她。
It's a funny kind of juvenile delinquent who's evading a social worker and his foster parents, and nobody knows where he is. And where he is, the bad thing he's doing, is going to visit his mom. Eventually Gene got in so much trouble for this he was sent away to a facility called Boys Home, 200 miles from Winston-Salem. He could come home 20 days a year, that was it. But at Boys Home, he finally got a more or less normal life. He made decent grades, got a girlfriend.
一个躲避社工和寄养父母的少年犯是个有趣的角色，没人知道他在哪。他正在做的“坏事”就是去探望他的妈妈。最终吉恩因此惹了太多麻烦，被送到一个叫“男童之家”的机构，距离温斯顿-塞勒姆200英里。他一年只能回家20天，仅此而已。但在“男童之家”，他终于过上了基本正常的生活。他成绩不错，有了女朋友。
I played sports. I was popular on campus. I fit in. My anger subsided some, mostly because of sports and those kind of things. And Boys Home was probably the best thing that happened to me. Because at this point in time, you're 200 miles away, and you know that you can't just walk across town and see your mom. So you resolve yourself to this fact, I'm not going home again.
我参加体育运动。我在校园里很受欢迎。我融入了。我的愤怒有所减轻，主要是因为体育运动之类的事情。“男童之家”可能是发生在我身上最好的事。因为这时候你离家200英里远，你知道你不能就这样横穿城市去见妈妈。所以你接受了这个事实：我再也不会回家了。
The first time that you heard about Tuck, Tuck was saying to your mom, maybe the two of them should split up for your sake.
你第一次听说塔克的时候，是塔克对你妈说，也许为了你好，他们俩应该分开。
Yeah.
是的。
Do you think he might have been right?
你觉得他当时可能说对了吗？
Well, in hindsight, absolutely. And in hindsight, yeah, they probably should have-- but I can tell you one thing. I wouldn't change one minute of my life. I have two wonderful brothers. Had that happened, I wouldn't have known Tuck. So I'm glad they didn't end it. To be honest with you, I'm glad. I'm happy. I wouldn't have it any other way.
嗯，事后看来，绝对是。事后看来，是的，他们大概应该……但我可以告诉你一件事。我不会改变我生命中的一分钟。我有两个很棒的兄弟。如果那样做了，我就不会认识塔克了。所以我很高兴他们没有结束。老实说，我很高兴。我很幸福。我不会要求任何改变。
Randy's grown up by now. Does he ever talk to you about the choice that you made then?
兰迪现在长大了。他有跟你谈过你当时做的那个决定吗？
Yeah, we've talked about it. Randy grew up thinking I was one of the knights of King Arthur's court.
是的，我们谈过。兰迪长大后认为我是亚瑟王圆桌骑士中的一员。
Because his parents had told him?
因为他父母告诉他的？
Absolutely. My mom and Tuck would tell him. So he worshipped-- like any little brother would, he worshiped me, but even more so, because in his mind, I had made this sacrifice for him.
当然。我妈妈和塔克会告诉他。所以他崇拜我——就像任何一个小弟弟一样，他崇拜我，甚至更多，因为在他心中，我为他做出了这种牺牲。
Well not even in his mind. You did make this sacrifice for him. He got to stay with his parents because of you.
嗯，甚至不仅仅是在他心中。你确实为他做出了这种牺牲。因为你，他才能和父母待在一起。
I know.
我知道。
Years later, you must have talked to your mom about that decision, about how Tuck raised very early the thought that maybe we should split up, because look at all the bad things that can happen. Did she have regrets about the choices that she made? Or mixed feelings about the choices she made?
多年后，你一定和你妈妈谈过那个决定，关于塔克很早之前就提出也许我们应该分开，因为看看会发生多少坏事。她对她所做的选择有后悔吗？或者对她所做的选择有复杂的感觉吗？
Oh, definitely. There's no question about it. She came to my graduation at Boys Home, and I'd been there five years by this time. And it was the first time that she had ever been to Boys Home. She rode the bus down and I picked her up at the bus station in one of Boys Home's cars. And we were going by campus and I said, Mom, do you want me to show you around? And she started crying, and she said, no, I can't do that honey. And I said, oh, it's OK, I understand. It was like we were living separate lives, and I was growing up without her.
噢，当然。毫无疑问。她来参加我在“男童之家”的毕业典礼，当时我在那里待了五年。那是她第一次去“男童之家”。她坐公交车下来，我用“男童之家的车在车站接她。我们要经过校园时，我说，妈，你想让我带你转转吗？她开始哭，她说，不，我做不到，孩子。我说，噢，没关系，我理解。当时感觉我们就像生活在两个世界里，我在没有她的情况下长大了。
And so she continued to cry, and I parked the car and stopped. And she just looked at me. And by this time we were both crying. And she just looked at me and she said, I'm so sorry.
她继续哭着，我把车停下。她只是看着我。那时候我们都在哭。她看着我说：“我很抱歉。”
Sorry that you had to be there at all?
抱歉让你不得不待在那儿吗？
Yeah. Sorry that things had happened the way they had. Well, I just looked at her and I told her, I said, sorry for what, mama? For loving me? For loving Randy? For loving Tuck? What do you have to be sorry for? That's when I told her that I had just spent five years with 104 boys who knew for a fact that no one in the world gave a hooting hell about them. The difference between me and them was that in my lifetime I had been loved. There was never a moment, never a moment, in my life when I did not know for a fact that I was loved. And I said, you don't have anything to be sorry for and you don't have to tell me you're sorry. You never have to say that to me.
是的。抱歉事情变成了那样。嗯，我看着她，我对她说：“抱歉什么，妈妈？抱歉爱我？抱歉爱兰迪？抱歉爱塔克？你有什么好抱歉的？”就在那时我告诉她，我刚刚和104个男孩待了五年，他们清楚地知道世界上没有人会在乎他们。我和他们不同之处在于，在我的一生中，我感受到过爱。我生命中从未有一刻，我不知道自己是被爱的。我说：“你什么都不用抱歉，你也不必对我说抱歉。你永远不必对我那样说。”
There's no question that it shortened her life and that it was something she carried with her. Guilt she carried with her every day of her life. And Tuck too. She used to ask my ex-wife how I felt about it and did I blame her? Even though we were close, very close, that's just something that can't be removed from a mother. And she was a loving mother so it was devastating for her.
毫无疑问，这缩短了她的寿命，这是她随身携带的负担。那是她一生中每天都在背负的愧疚。塔克也是。她过去常问我前妻，我对这件事感觉如何，我是否责怪她？即使我们很亲近，非常亲近，那也是母亲无法释怀的东西。她是个充满母爱的母亲，所以这对她来说是毁灭性的。
Gene Cheek. He's written a book about his family's story called The Color Of Love: A Mother's Choice In the Jim Crow South. The US Supreme Court ruled in 1967 that state laws that prevented interracial marriage were unconstitutional. But North Carolina only got around to following the Supreme Court's orders on this matter in 1974. It was after that finally that Gene's mom was able to marry Tuck. They had another son, and lived out their days together. Tuck died in 1982. Gene's mom died in 1995.
吉恩·奇克。他写了一本关于他家庭故事的书，名叫《爱的颜色：吉姆·克劳南方的一位母亲的选择》。美国最高法院于1967年裁定，各州禁止跨种族婚姻的法律违宪。但北卡罗来纳州直到1974年才开始遵守最高法院的裁决。在那之后，吉恩的妈妈才终于能够嫁给塔克。他们又生了一个儿子，度过了余生。塔克于1982年去世。吉恩的妈妈于1995年去世。
Coming up, grandmas rush in where wise men never go. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，奶奶们会冲进智者不敢涉足的地方。一会儿回来，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Parental Guidance Suggested, stories of kids who need parents to step in and fix things, and what those kids end up doing when the parents fail to act. We've arrived at act two of our show. Act two, The Grandma Letters. In this act, as in our first act, a boy finds himself far from the home he knows and the world he knows. But in this case, the adults in his life seem to stop guiding him effectively, even once he gets to high school. So instead, he turns to the postal system. Will Seymour told this story on stage as part of The Mortified Stage Show, where people read from embarrassing old diaries and letters.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，《需要家长指导》，讲述了那些需要父母介入解决问题的孩子的故事，以及当父母失职时，那些孩子最终做了什么。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，奶奶的信。在这一幕中，正如我们第一幕那样，一个男孩发现自己远离了他熟悉的家和他熟悉的世界。但在这个案例中，他生活中的成年人在他上高中后似乎就停止了有效地指导他。所以相反，他转向了邮政系统。比尔·西摩在《受羞耻舞台秀》上现场讲述了这个故事，人们在秀上读出令人尴尬的旧日记和信件。
In 1981, I was fine. I had pets, and my parents were married, and my grandparents lived next door. All was well. And then my parents divorced. I had to give up my pets and I had to move. We moved far away. And so my best friend, of course, was my grandmother, and she lived far, far away. And back in the '80s, there was long distance phone, very expensive. So I had no one. I started a new school, and I had no friends, except my grandmother.
1981年，我很好。我有宠物，我父母结婚了，祖父母住隔壁。一切都很好。然后我父母离婚了。我不得不放弃我的宠物，我不得不搬家。我们搬到了很远的地方。所以我的好朋友当然是我祖母，她住得非常非常远。而在80年代，长途电话非常贵。所以我谁也没有。我开始上新学校，我没有朋友，除了我祖母。
So I wrote my grandmother letters, a lot of letters. And I'm not going to read all of them. And she wrote me back. She was probably pretty worried about us and I shared nothing but terrible information. [LAUGHTER] And then just so you know, she was kind of dying of emphysema, so she had really terrible information too. She actually wrote me back and treated me like an adult and we actually became really good friends. So here's a couple of our little exchanges. This is like 1981, freshman in high school.
所以我给祖母写信，写了很多信。我不打算读所有的。她也回信给我。她可能很担心我们，而我只分享了糟糕的信息。（笑声）而且你知道，她当时患肺气肿快要去世了，所以她也有非常糟糕的信息。她实际上回信给我，像对待成年人一样对待我，我们真的成了非常好的朋友。所以这是我们的一些交流。这是1981年，高中一年级的时候。
Dear Grandma, I hate it here. I'm faking sick today and I'm staying home, just like yesterday. [LAUGHTER] I'm so afraid of school. Hopefully I can change my schedule out of PE and maybe like a library aide or something. I lost more weight. I just don't get hungry. I get worried when I lose my hunger. And when I worry, I don't get hungry. [LAUGHTER] Grandma, don't feel bad if you're too sick to write back. Feel terrible. Just kidding. Well, it was wonderful talking to you. [LAUGHTER] I love you, and I miss you, Bill Seymour, your grandson. [LAUGHTER]
亲爱的奶奶，我讨厌这里。我今天装病待在家里，就像昨天一样。（笑声）我太害怕学校了。希望我能把体育课换掉，换成图书馆助理什么的。我又瘦了。我就是没胃口。当我失去胃口时我会很担心。当我担心时，我就没有胃口。（笑声）奶奶，如果你病得写不动信了，也别难过。感觉糟透了吧。开玩笑的。嗯，和你通话很棒。（笑声）我爱你，我想你，比尔·西摩，你的孙子。（笑声）
Bill dear, I guess our wonderful chats on the phone are a thing of the past, since neither of us can afford them. Well, we can still write. We miss all of you something fierce. I'm sorry my writing is terrible, I've become so messy. But it's not me. I'm back on triple strength antibiotics. My medication speeds up my metabolism and causes these trembly hands. [LAUGHTER] Well, enough of this [BLEEP], here's a joke. Do you know what they call 10 rabbits walking backwards? A receding hare line. Ask your mother to explain it. Well honey, I guess I'll close for this one. Keep the letters coming. They really help, Bill. Love, Grandma.
亲爱的比尔，我想我们美好的电话长谈已经成为过去了，因为我们谁都负担不起。好吧，我们还可以写信。我们非常想念你们所有人。抱歉我的书写太糟糕了，我变得笨手笨脚了。但这不怪我。我又用回了三倍强度的抗生素。药物加快了我的新陈代谢，导致了这些颤抖的手。（笑声）好吧，这些破事够了，这里有个笑话。你知道他们怎么称呼10只向后走的兔子吗？“后退的野兔线”。让你妈妈解释一下。嗯亲爱的，我想这次就写到这。保持写信。它们真的很有帮助，比尔。爱你的，奶奶。
Hello, Grandma. School's not great. It's just OK. I'm kind of worried about algebra and French. Actually, my grades are OK, considering I don't go to school for very much. [LAUGHTER] I am writing you right now from class. Love, Bill Seymour, your grandson. PS, I put my last name, just in case you forgot. [LAUGHTER] What the hell?
你好，奶奶。学校不太好。还行吧。我有点担心代数和法语。其实，考虑到我没怎么去学校，我的成绩还行。（笑声）我现在是在课堂上给你写信。爱你的，比尔·西摩，你的孙子。附注：我加上了我的姓，以防你忘了。（笑声）搞什么鬼？
Hi, Grandma. It's special Thursday. Want to know why? Today I went to school and I found out I'm behind in my French class. Just kidding, it's no big. But seriously, I'm failing my French class. [LAUGHTER] How are you? I'm OK, not great. I didn't take the bus today. I cut my last class and I walked home instead. They were throwing pee balloons, because the water was shut off at school. It was a long walk but at least I don't have pee on me. [LAUGHTER] Love Bill, your bored grandson. [LAUGHTER]
嗨，奶奶。今天是特别的星期四。想知道为什么吗？今天我去了学校，发现我的法语课落后了。开玩笑的，没关系。但说真的，我的法语课要不及格了。（笑声）你怎么样？我还可以，不怎么好。我今天没坐校车。我逃了最后一节课，自己走回家了。他们在扔尿气球，因为学校停水了。路很远，但至少我身上没有尿。（笑声）爱你的，无聊的孙子，比尔。（笑声）
Bill dear, I'm getting a mask. It sterilizes the air that I breathe in, but I hope they come in colors. I'd like to get one that matches my eyes, but gramps says they don't come in bloodshot, [BLEEP] brindle brown. [LAUGHTER] Bill, [LAUGHTER] you said you were bored. I'll show you bored. Things are so bad here I squeezed the Charmin twice this morning, just for the hell of it. [LAUGHTER] I know I shouldn't say hell, but who cares? I'm pretty sure God understands. Write soon, and keep smiling. All our love, Grandma and Grandpa.
亲爱的比尔，我得戴个口罩。它能消毒我呼吸的空气，但我希望它们有颜色的。我想要个和眼睛颜色匹配的，但爷爷说没有“血丝状、该死的棕色”。（笑声）比尔，（笑声）你说你很无聊。我会让你看看什么是无聊。这里情况很糟糕，我今天早上把卫生纸捏了两次，纯粹是为了好玩。（笑声）我知道我不该说该死的，但谁在乎呢？我相信上帝会理解的。快写信，保持微笑。我们的爱，奶奶和爷爷。
Hello, Grandma. How are you? Hello Gram. Yesterday and today were snow days, no school. I'm fine with that. Too many people said they were going to beat me up this week. I miss you both. Update: I'm now going to give you my opinion of mom's current boyfriend, soon to be husband, Phil. Well, he's super. Super terrible, super spectacularly fake, and full of super creepy personality. [LAUGHTER] Now for a few jokes. Have you heard the joke about the two girls playing jump rope? Oh, just skip it. Ha, ha, ha, ha. Love, Bill.
你好，奶奶。你好吗？你好奶奶。昨天和今天都是雪天，不上学。我对此没意见。这周有太多人说要揍我了。我想念你们俩。更新：我现在要给你我的观点，关于妈妈现在的男朋友，即将成为丈夫的菲尔。嗯，他太棒了。超级糟糕，超级假，而且充满超级令人毛骨悚然的个性。（笑声）现在来几个笑话。听过关于两个女孩跳绳的笑话吗？噢，别跳了。哈哈哈哈。爱你的，比尔。
Dear Bill, so nice to get your long letter, honey. Still flat on my back, so writing is really difficult. [LAUGHTER] I'm going to try to use my walker today. Perhaps I'll be strong enough. How is school going? I imagine it's not the happy place it should be, but honey, hang tough. Keep at it. Time will pass quickly. And as for your impression of Phil, your mom has never really mentioned him in detail, or for that matter, de-head or de-mind either. [LAUGHTER] Your jokes are funny. Have you heard of these? What would you give a pig with a sore throat? Oinkment. What lies on the ocean floor and twitches? A nervous wreck. Ha, ha, ha, ha. Well love, coughing, no time for me. I've got to get on my breathing machine. I never coughed so good when I was smoking. We love you, Grandma.
亲爱的比尔，收到你的长信真好，亲爱的。还是躺在背上，所以写作真的很困难。（笑声）我今天要试着走走我的助行器。也许我会强壮一点。学校进展如何？我想它不是它本该成为的那个快乐的地方，但亲爱的，坚持住。继续努力。时间会过得很快。至于你对菲尔的印象，你妈妈从未真正详细地提到他，或者就此而言，没有提到他的头脑。（笑声）你的笑话很有趣。你听过这些吗？你会给喉咙痛的猪什么？“药膏”。什么躺在海底抽搐？“一个神经质的残骸”。哈哈哈哈。好吧，爱你的，咳嗽着，我没时间了。我得去用我的呼吸机了。我抽烟时从来没咳得这么好过。我们爱你，奶奶。
Dear Grandma, this fun kit has been made especially by me to get you well. And it's basically, I made about seven of them. And they're about 14 pages long, each of them. And this particular one had a quiz in it. Hey you, do you think you're smart? You think you've got the know how in the noggin? OK, just to be perfectly sure, take today's quiz to find out how smart you really are. Number one, Babe Ruth was famous for hitting A, the bottle; B, his mother in law; or C, small children with a baseball bat? [LAUGHTER] Number two, Typhoid Mary was infamous for spreading A, rumors; B, dirty mouse breath; or C, a feverishly hot stew? Number three, Beethoven played A, the field; B, shuffleboard; or C, because he was an artist, damn it. He was an artist.
亲爱的奶奶，这个有趣的工具包是我专门为你做的，让你康复。基本上，我做了大约七个。它们每个大约有14页长。而这一特别的有一个测验在里面。嘿你，你觉得你聪明吗？你觉得你脑袋里有智慧吗？好的，为了百分之百确定，参加今天的测验来看看你到底有多聪明。第一题，贝比·鲁斯因为撞击什么而闻名？A，酒瓶；B，他的岳母；或者C，用棒球棒打小孩？（笑声）第二题，“伤寒玛丽”因为传播什么而臭名昭著？A，谣言；B，脏老鼠的气息；或者C，热腾腾的炖菜？第三题，贝多芬演奏什么？A，场地；B，沙弧球；或者C，因为他是个艺术家，该死的。他是个艺术家。
And then the last letter. Bill dear, it always gives me such a warm feeling to write those words. We've always had such a special relationship, haven't we? You're not only a loving grandson, you've been a friend, and that's a real treasure. I've needed to tell you of my love for you, so you will be able to wear it like a warm jacket for as long as you want, something that no one or nothing can take away from you. You've always made me happy. I love you, Grandma. Over. PS, when I hear this song, I think of you. It's the theme of the TV show Love , Sydney with Tony Randall. [LAUGHTER] Please believe me, lately my whole world is changing. Suddenly you're here, and life is better than before. We're like friends forever. And when the rest are gone, it's you who will be there for me, my friend. Thanks. [APPLAUSE]
然后是最后一封信。亲爱的比尔，写这些话总是给我一种温暖的感觉。我们一直有种特殊的关系，不是吗？你不仅是一个充满爱的孙子，你还是一个朋友，那是一个真正的财富。我需要告诉你我爱你，这样你就能够像穿上一件温暖的夹克一样穿着它，只要你想，任何人和任何事都不能从你那里夺走它。你总是让我快乐。我爱你，奶奶。完毕。附注：当我听到这首歌时，我会想到你。它是电视节目《爱，悉尼》的主题曲，托尼·兰德尔主演的那部。（笑声）请相信我，最近我的整个世界都在改变。突然你在这里，生活比以前更美好。我们就像永远的朋友。当其余的人都离开时，是你会在那里陪我，我的朋友。谢谢。（掌声）
Will Seymour lives in Los Angeles, where he is still avoiding French class. He read at The Mortified Stage Show. You can find them on the web at getmortified.com.
比尔·西摩住在洛杉矶，他依然在逃避法语课。他是在《受羞耻舞台秀》上读的。你可以在getmortified.com网站上找到他们。
[MUSIC - "THEME FROM THE TELEVISION CHOW LOVE, SYDNEY"]
（音乐 - 电视节目《爱，悉尼》主题曲）
Act three, My Angel's in the Centerfold. There's a story that my mom used to tell about when my sisters and I were little. The Gosgoth's cat next door to us had kittens. My sister Randi was six or seven at the time, and she asked my mom, OK, so how exactly did that happen? Like what happened to make the cat pregnant? And my mom, she just thought like, oh, this is really great. She's asking me these questions. We can get this out of the way. She's so young. And so she tells Randi the whole story and reproduction, and the mommy and the daddy cat, the whole thing. She gets to the end of this whole story. My mom is feeling great. And she turns to Randi and she says, do you have any questions, Randi? And Randi thinks for a second and she says, can birds really fly?
第三幕，折页里的天使。我妈妈过去常讲一个故事，关于我和姐妹们小时候的事。隔壁高斯格思家的猫生了小猫。我妹妹兰迪当时六七岁，她问我妈，“好的，那到底是怎么发生的？猫是怎么怀孕的？”我妈当时想，噢，这太好了。她在问我这些问题。我们可以把这事搞定。她还那么小。于是她给兰迪讲了关于繁殖的整个故事，猫妈妈和猫爸爸，整个过程。她讲完了整个故事。我妈感觉很棒。她转向兰迪说，“兰迪，你有什么问题吗？”兰迪想了一会儿说，“鸟真的会飞吗？”
I think the moral of the story is you can throw certain information at kids, but they're only going to absorb what they are able to absorb, and they're going to ignore everything else. And I bring this up here, because our next story is very much an example of that phenomenon. A warning to listeners, there's nothing explicit or graphic in this story, but it does acknowledge the existence of sex. Thea Chaloner tells the tale.
我想这故事的寓意是你可以向孩子们灌输某些信息，但他们只会吸收他们能够吸收的，他们会忽略其他一切。我在这里提到这一点，是因为我们的下一个故事非常符合那种现象。对听众的警告，这个故事中没有什么露骨或生动的内容，但它确实承认了性的存在。西娅·查洛纳讲述了这个故事。
My friend Emily had a rough time growing up with her dad. Part of the problem was his job. He taught human sexuality at Boston University, which is pretty impressive. But to a kid, it's your worst nightmare. Your dad is a sex professor. By the time she was 10, he was a local celebrity, famous for his knowledge about sex.
我的朋友艾米丽在和她爸爸成长的过程中度过了一段艰难的时期。问题的一部分是他的工作。他在波士顿大学教人类性学，这很令人印象深刻。但对一个孩子来说，这是你最糟糕的噩梦。你爸爸是个性学教授。到她10岁时，他已经是当地名人，以他的性知识闻名。
He had a radio show on WHDH in Boston called Talking Sex with Doctor Joseph Helfgot . It was a call-in show. And it was a maverick show of its time because he would talk frankly about sex. Most of the people who called in were women talking about how-- I mean, I can clearly remember, I can hear a woman's voice calling in and asking if he could explain to her how she could achieve multiple orgasm. So at Rebecca Ritter's house, fifth grade, in my Care Bear nightgown, in my Strawberry Shortcake sleeping bag, I swear to God, as like girly as it gets. And then we are in our sleeping bags about to go to sleep, and Rebecca sits up and says, let's listen to Em's dad's show.
他在波士顿的WHDH有一个广播节目，叫《与约瑟夫·赫尔夫戈特博士谈性》。这是一个观众打进电话的节目。那是当时一个特立独行的节目，因为他会坦率地谈论性。大多数打电话进来的都是女性，谈论如何……我的意思是，我可以清楚地记得，我能听到一个女人的声音打进来，问他能否向她解释如何才能达到多重高潮。所以当时在丽贝卡·里特家，五年级，我穿着我的“关心熊”睡衣，钻在我的“草莓短饼”睡袋里，我发誓，真的不能再女孩气了。然后我们在睡袋里准备睡觉，丽贝卡坐起来说：“听听艾姆爸爸的节目吧。”
So they turn the radio on and we'd be like in the dark, listening to my father on the radio going, [EXHALES]-- because he also smoked-- Doris, I'm really glad you called in. Women so often think that it's something that's going on with them, that's the reason why they can't achieve multiple orgasm. And he was very flirtatious with the people on the air, too. And I knew that, I could sense the tenor of the flirtation, even when I was a little kid. And I was trying to pass it off and be giggly and like, oh, it's so funny, like all my friends were. But I was putting my nails into my thigh to get myself not to cry. And I also just felt, why couldn't my dad be normal?
所以他们打开收音机，我们就在黑暗中，听我父亲在收音机里说——（呼气）——因为他也抽烟——“多丽丝，我很高兴你打来电话。女性通常认为那是她们自己的原因导致无法达到多重高潮。”他对节目里的那些人也很调情。我知道那点，即使我还是个小孩子，我也能感觉到那种调情的语气。我试图把它掩盖过去，笑嘻嘻地，像我所有朋友一样。但我把指甲掐进大腿里，让自己别哭出来。我也只是觉得，为什么我爸爸就不能正常一点呢？
Emily's parents divorced when she was five, and she and her brother spent every other weekend at her dad's house. He enforced a lot of family time, which usually meant watching TV. Then he'd fall asleep and the kids were left to amuse themselves. Her brother occupied himself with Archie comics and GI Joes But Emily was on her own. It was weird being there, and boring, until she discovered the bookshelves.
艾米丽的父母在她五岁时离婚，她和哥哥每隔一个周末就去她爸爸家。他强制要求很多家庭时间，通常就是看电视。然后他会睡着，孩子们就只能自己找乐子。她哥哥摆弄阿奇漫画和特种部队人偶。但艾米丽只能靠自己。在那里感觉很怪，很无聊，直到她发现了书架。
It was all books on the top three bookshelves, and then the bottom bookshelf was all Playboys . I mean, it was like a 64 Crayola box of Playboys . And my first mission, because I was always a very kind of organizationally oriented kid, was to chronologically organize them. So I had them going October '81, or whatever it was, all the way through to whatever the current one was. Somehow-- and I wish I could tell you how I figured this out-- I decided that I would use the magazines, and kind of use the centerfolds and the questionnaires that they would answer, as a portfolio for women who I would use in my dating service.
书架顶上三层全是书，然后最下面一层全是《花花公子》。我的意思是，那就像一盒64色的《花花公子》蜡笔。我的第一个任务，因为我一直是一个非常有组织倾向的孩子，就是按年代整理它们。所以我把它们从81年10月，或者不管是什么时候，一直排到最新的一本。不知怎么的——我真希望能告诉你我是怎么想出来的——我决定我将使用这些杂志，把折页和她们回答的问卷作为我婚介服务中女性的个人资料。
The tools for her imaginary dating service were: a Smith Corona typewriter, a phone unplugged from the wall, a box of index cards, a Yellow Pages, and of course, a huge collection of Playboys .
她虚构的婚介服务的工具是：一台史密斯-科罗纳打字机、一部从墙上拔掉插头的电话、一盒索引卡、一本黄页，当然，还有一大堆《花花公子》杂志。
Take me through a couple of sample scenarios of what this would be. Can you do that?
带我看看这些情况的一些样本场景。你能做到吗？
I can, but I should, as the disclaimer, first say that I would say my lines out loud, but I wouldn't say the lines of the quote unquote, "person on the other line of the phone." [PHONE RING] Miss Lana's Dating Service, how can I help you? Uh-huh. So you're looking for someone who's like 5'10", and weighs 125 pounds? Can you hold on for just a minute, sir? And then I would press-- actually, I don't believe there was a hold button, but in my imagination there was, and I would put the phone down. And I would go to my resource library of Playboy magazines, and I would go until I found someone that was around the range that I had just made up for myself. So really it's very twisted.
我可以，但我应该先声明一下，我会大声说出我的台词，但我不会说出“电话那头的人”的台词。（电话铃响）“兰娜小姐婚介服务，有什么能帮您的？”“嗯哼。所以你在找一个大约5英尺10英寸、体重125磅的人？您能稍微等一下吗，先生？”然后我会按——其实我不认为有一个保持通话按钮，但在我的想象中是有，我会放下电话。我会去我的《花花公子》杂志资源库，一直翻到找到一个符合我刚刚为自己编造的范围的人。所以这真的很扭曲。
And then I would open up to the centerfolds, and not really extend the whole picture of the centerfold, but really just looking at the questionnaire. And once I had that in front of me, I'd get back on the phone. Hi, Mr. Watkins? Yes, I think I have the perfect girl for you. Her name is Amber Rose. She is 5'9", 125 pounds, and she-- what? Yes, she does. She likes oysters, and she likes long walks on the beach at night. And oh, she loves shooting stars. Does that sound good? OK, Mr. Watkins, let me just get your information. And then I would put an index card in the typewriter, and roll it in. It was one of those old manual kind.
然后我会翻开折页，并没有真正展开整张图片，只是真正看着调查问卷。一旦我面前有了那个，我就回到电话上。“喂，沃特金斯先生？是的，我想我有一个完美的女孩给你。她叫安布尔·罗斯。她5英尺9英寸，125磅，她——什么？是的，她确实。她喜欢牡蛎，她喜欢晚上在海滩上散步。噢，她喜欢流星。那听起来不错吗？好的，沃特金斯先生，我只要获取一下你的信息。”然后我会把一张索引卡放进打字机里，卷进去。那是那种老式的机械打字机。
And I would say, so it's Ron Watkins. And it would take me hunting and pecking on the typewriter, like Ron Watkins, spell it out, return, next line. And then I would type in the name of the centerfold. I've typed in the magazine she was from, like the month and the year so I'd have it for reference later. And then I would chat sometimes with him on the phone, like, so Mr. Watkins, how long have you been living in Washington? Uh-huh. Oh, you got a recommendation from-- oh, yeah, Bill comes to me all the time.
我会说：“所以是罗恩·沃特金斯。”我会用打字机边找边按，像这样：“罗恩·沃特金斯”，拼出来，回车，下一行。然后我会打入折页女孩的名字。我打进她所属的杂志，比如月份和年份，这样我以后可以查阅。有时我还会和他聊天，“所以沃特金斯先生，你在华盛顿住多久了？嗯哼。噢，你是得到推荐的……噢，是的，比尔经常来找我。”
And I was a facilitator of the woman and the man getting together. I wasn't playing out any kind of fantasy for myself. I was a businesswoman.
我是促成男女相见的中间人。我没有在为自己演绎任何幻想。我是一个女商人。
Except for the fact that the women are totally naked, in very sexual positions all throughout these magazines. So did that factor into your brain?
除了一个事实，那就是这些杂志里到处都是裸体女性，姿势非常色情。这有进入你的大脑吗？
No, that's why I say that I really-- I mean, I would look at the actual pictures, really just so I could get a sense, because sometimes they were like, cowgirl. Like she would have no clothes on except for she'd have a bullwhip in her hand, and little spurs on her ankles, and she'd be lying on a bed of hay or something. So I would factor that into my conversation with the guy. I'd be like, and she loves to rodeo.
不，这就是为什么我说我真的……我的意思是，我会看那些真实的图片，真的只是为了有个概念，因为有时她们像是在骑马。比如她没穿衣服，除了手里拿着一根牛鞭，脚踝上戴着小马刺，躺在一堆干草之类的东西上。所以我会在和男人的谈话中考虑这一点。我会说：“而且她热爱骑术。”
So then I took it to this other level. This is where the Yellow Pages comes in. Where I would say, so Ron, what kind of cuisine do you like? And I would find a place, and then I would type up on the index card the name of the restaurant, the time the reservation was going to be, and I filed the card away, I'm sure alphabetically, by the guy's last name in the little plastic case. And then it was time for the next call.
所以后来我把它提升到了另一个层次。这就是黄页发挥作用的地方。我会说：“所以罗恩，你喜欢什么口味的美食？”我会找一家店，然后把餐厅名称、预订时间打在索引卡上，我肯定把卡片按字母顺序放在了那个小塑料盒里。然后就是下一个电话的时间了。
I could not have been more content. I always wanted to be a travel agent as a kid, you know the clicking, clicking of the nails on the keyboard, and the simultaneously talking to-- and this was before I think they even had headset phones. So the simultaneous talking to the person, I think I have a good deal for you, and then like referencing things in books, just using all those tools. And the resources available to me were Playboy magazines.
我当时非常满足。我小时候一直想当旅行社职员，你知道敲击键盘的咔嗒声，还有同时和人交谈——这在我认为他们甚至有耳机电话之前。所以同时和人交谈，“我想我有一个好交易给你”，然后从书里找东西，只是使用所有那些工具。我能利用的资源就是《花花公子》杂志。
It was also just a coping mechanism for being in an environment that I hated. I didn't like being there for so many reasons, and it was an escape.
这同样是一种应对机制，为了应付一个我讨厌的环境。我讨厌在那里待着的原因有很多，这是一种逃避。
For Emily, the long term effects of looking at so many Playboys at such a young age weren't as damaging as you'd expect. When she was 10, she believed that she could choose the centerfold body she liked the best, and then she'd grow into it later on, like that was an option. What was damaging was that her dad just didn't seem to get that she was still a kid and that certain things were better left unsaid. Or in the case of the Playboys , certain things are better left stashed away on that top shelf of the closet.
对艾米丽来说，在这么小的年纪看这么多《花花公子》的长期影响并不像你想象的那么具破坏性。10岁时，她相信她可以挑选她最喜欢的折页身材，然后以后长成那样，就像那是个选项一样。具破坏性的是，她爸爸似乎不明白她还是个孩子，有些事情最好不要说。或者在《花花公子》的情况下，有些事情最好收在壁橱的最上面那一层。
A 10 year old, 11 year old, 12 year old girl is not impressed by her father's call in radio sex show. She's not impressed by the fact that he can talk so openly about sex, because as far as she's concerned, that conversation doesn't exist between the father and the daughter. I think what you have to understand is that to cope as a kid, you read a situation when you walk into it, and you conform to the situation. And being able to enter into this-- especially from the world of my mother's house, that was like everything was in its right place, and we got tucked in. And I got my back rubbed in a very certain way. And the door left open just three inches, and then good night, sweet dreams, I love you, with the glass of water. And it's like, we're going to dad's, a different routine. I can fight it and be miserable or I can kind of make a game up with the Playboys until we get back to my mom's house.
一个10岁、11岁、12岁的女孩不会对她爸爸的电台性节目印象深刻。她不会因为他能如此公开地谈论性而留下印象，因为据她看来，那种对话不存在于父女之间。我认为你必须明白的是，作为孩子为了应对，当你走进一个环境时，你会解读它，并顺应它。能够进入这个——尤其是从我妈妈房子的世界走出来，那里一切都井然有序，我们被塞进被子里。我的背会以一种特定的方式被抚摸。门只留开三英寸，然后晚安，甜蜜的梦，我爱你，还有那杯水。这感觉就是，“我们要去爸爸那了，换个流程。”我可以反抗并变得悲惨，或者我可以一边玩《花花公子》的游戏，一边等我们回到我妈妈家。
Well, it's like, I can fight it, or I can alphabetize.
嗯，就像是，“我可以反抗，或者我可以按字母排序。”
Yes, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
Emily lost her virginity when she was 17. She told both parents. Her mom's first response was sweet: do you love him? Were you safe? Her dad's? Was it good? Did you orgasm? And yes, at the time, her dad's question completely freaked her out. But now she thinks his intentions were the same as her mom's. His heart was in the right place. He just didn't understand how to talk to his daughter. It's the oldest dad problem in the world.
艾米丽在17岁时失去了童贞。她告诉了父母双方。她妈妈的第一反应很甜：“你爱他吗？你做好安全措施了吗？”她爸爸呢？“那感觉好吗？你达到高潮了吗？”是的，当时她爸爸的问题彻底让她崩溃了。但现在她认为他的意图和她妈妈的一样。他的心在正确的地方。他只是不明白如何和女儿沟通。这是世界上最古老的父亲问题。
Thea Chaloner. She was, until last week, our intern here at This American Life . She's moving back to Los Angeles to become a producer at public radio station KCRW.
西娅·查洛纳。直到上周，她还是我们《美国生活》的实习生。她要搬回洛杉矶，去公共广播电台KCRW担任制作人。
[MUSIC - "TRUMP STYLE" BY KIMYA DAWSON]
（音乐 - 金雅·道森的《特朗普风格》）
Our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and Sativa January. Special thanks today to Jordana Gustufsson. You know you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、黛安·库克、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特经营我们的网站。塞思·林德和萨提瓦·詹努里提供了制作协助。今天特别感谢乔丹娜·古斯塔夫森。你知道你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载今天的节目存档。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助鸣谢）
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who said to me just the other day--.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他前几天刚对我说了——。
When I hear this song, I think of you. It's the theme of the TV show Love, Sydney with Tony Randall.
当我听到这首歌时，我会想到你。它是电视节目《爱，悉尼》的主题曲，托尼·兰德尔主演的那部。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。